This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidanthan. These days we know how important it is for young children to feel loved. Parents are encouraged to sit with their kids, read to them, hug them, make them feel safe. But believe it or not, this wasn't always the case. It's so fascinating to look back on that period and think to yourself how could you get that so wrong. This is writer Deborah Blum. She's looked closely at what caused the revolution in psychology around how best to parent children. The early
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹特姆。如今，我们深知让幼儿感受到爱是多么重要。家长们被鼓励多陪陪孩子，给他们读书，拥抱他们，让他们感到安全。但信不信由你，过去并非总是如此。回看那段时期，心里不禁会想，怎么会错得这么离谱。这是作家黛博拉·布鲁姆。她深入研究了引发心理学关于如何最好地养育孩子这一革命的原因。早期的
books told mothers not to hold their children at all if they could avoid it that it would ruin the moral fiber of the child. We'll hear more about the effects of loving touch and its absence in a moment. We turn to one of our colleagues, Alison McCatum, for a personal story about the importance of affection, touch, and attachment. Allison is an editor at NPR and she has a secret. I'm just going to come out and say it.
书籍告诉母亲们，如果能避免，就绝不要抱孩子，因为这会毁掉孩子的道德品质。稍后我们将听到更多关于充满爱的触摸及其缺失的影响。我们转向我们的同事艾莉森·麦卡达姆，听一个关于爱抚、触摸和依恋之重要性的个人故事。艾莉森是NPR的一名编辑，她有一个秘密。我只想直截了当地说出来。
I sleep with my blanket, my baby blanket. Here's what it looks like. It's a white woven cotton, it's a little thread bear. It is the softest thing in the world. And even on the hottest days, it feels cool. When I bury my nose in it, it smells like comfort. As a baby, apparently, I called it Baba. So, of course, I still call it Baba.
我和我的毯子一起睡觉，我的婴儿毯。这是它的样子。它是一种白色的机织棉布，有点磨损起毛。它是世界上最柔软的东西。即使在最热的日子里，它也感觉很凉爽。当我把鼻子埋在上面时，它闻起来像是安慰。作为一个婴儿，显然我叫它“巴巴”。所以，当然，我仍然叫它“巴巴”。
Are you rolling your eyes yet? This is embarrassing to admit. And that's because I feel like society tells me I should have given up my blanket a long time ago. I did a quick Google search and I found all sorts of posts about when and how to wean your child off a blanket. And that's when, not if. Here's an example.
你已经在翻白眼了吗？这承认起来真让人尴尬。这是因为我觉得社会在告诉我，我早就该戒掉这条毯子了。我快速用谷歌搜索了一下，找到了各种关于何时以及如何让孩子戒掉毯子的帖子。而且重点是“何时”，而不是“是否”。这里有一个例子。
One of those posts claims that psychologists have a wide range of opinions on when children should give up their blankets, but it says, it is advisable to have overcome this hurdle by the time the child is attending kindergarten. Well, I have not overcome my Baba. And I'm convinced I'm not alone. I know that some of you also crawl into bed and snuggle each night with a soft inanimate object. Do you hide it? Are you ashamed? Even my mom, my very affectionate mom, who gave me no shortage of hugs, even she is befuddled about my blanket. I asked her about it. I want to know what you think of the fact that I still sleep with my baba.
其中一篇帖子声称，心理学家对于孩子什么时候应该扔掉毯子有各种各样的看法，但它说，最好在孩子上幼儿园之前克服这个难关。好吧，我还没有克服我的“巴巴”。而且我确信我并不孤单。我知道你们当中也有人每晚爬上床，和一个柔软的无生命物体依偎在一起。你把它藏起来了吗？你感到羞耻吗？甚至我妈妈，那个非常慈爱的妈妈，给了我数不清的拥抱，甚至她也对我的毯子感到困惑。我问过她这件事。我想知道你对我还抱着“巴巴”睡觉这件事怎么看。
I think it's a little bizarre. Why is that? I think that's something you usually outgrow and give up as you become older and more secure and comfortable. And you never did. And I was pretty amazed when it went away to college with you. And I'm certainly amazed that you still sleep with it. Did you hear her words?
我觉得这有点怪异。为什么这么说？我认为随着你年龄的增长，变得更加自信和舒适，这通常是你应该摆脱并放弃的东西。而你从来没有。当它跟着你一起去上大学时，我非常惊讶。而且我当然很惊讶你现在还抱着它睡觉。你听到她的话了吗？
Bizarre. You outgrow it, she says, as you become more secure, more comfortable, out. Words like this, they creep inside you and they park there. If you're wondering how old I am, the answer is, I turn 40 this year. I married, I have a child, and I've thought about this question a lot. Is my Baba a sign that I'm a failed adult, insecure, immature? One day I got this email. It was from my brother, he lives in Chicago,
怪异。她说，随着你变得更自信、更舒适，你会摆脱它。这样的话语，它们会潜入你的内心并在那里驻留。如果你想知道我多大，答案是，我今年40岁了。我结婚了，有了一个孩子，我思考过这个问题很多次。我的“巴巴”是我是一个失败的成年人、不自信、不成熟的标志吗？有一天我收到了这封电子邮件。那是我的兄弟发来的，他住在芝加哥，
and he was hanging out with a friend of his, who also sleeps with a blanket. And he told me, she seems really tough, but she has a heart of gold. I thought, why don't I meet this woman? And that led me to a dark rock club in Chicago. It's called the Empty Bottle. ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M
他和他的一个朋友在一起，那个朋友也抱着毯子睡觉。他告诉我，她看起来真的很强硬，但她有一颗金子般的心。我想，我为什么不认识一下这位女士呢？这把我带到了芝加哥的一个黑漆漆的摇滚俱乐部。它叫空瓶子俱乐部。["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M
It was the beginning of the night a band was sound checking. ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M It would be 450 please. ["M It's a cash on me by.
那是夜晚的开始，一支乐队正在试音。["M ["M ["M ["M ["M ["M 请付450。["M 我这只收现金。
And that's bartender Aaron Page. I would say that I'm a pretty classic punk rag venue bartender. Give you a shot in your beer and then you go away and have a good time. Aaron Page, black hair, tattoos, upper arms, she sleeps with her baby blanket. I asked Aaron if spending evenings in a loud bar makes her long for her blanket. Oh yeah, all the time, every night. Every night on my life, I go home and I get in my bed and I put the blanket on my head or under my head usually is the best.
那是调酒师亚伦·佩奇。我会说我是一个相当典型的朋克摇滚场地调酒师。给你来一杯烈酒配啤酒，然后你走开，玩得开心。亚伦·佩奇，黑发，上臂有纹身，她抱着她的婴儿毯睡觉。我问亚伦，在喧闹的酒吧度过夜晚是否会让她的渴望毯子。哦，是的，一直都在，每天晚上。我生活中的每个夜晚，我回家上床睡觉，把毯子盖在头上，或者垫在头底下，通常这样最好。
Here's what really strikes me about Erin. She feels none of the shame I feel about being a full grown adult with a blanket. She and I talked about that somewhere quieter at her apartment. When she's not bartending, Erin plays in a punk rock band and she designs poster art. Her walls are decorated with that art and it has a distinctive goth style. Like, this is what I'm working on right now. There's the skull and some the devil and some eyeballs and this woman and a trance. Aaron told me her art is an expression of a child's imagination. And her blankie is kind of the same thing. It's
真正让我对亚伦印象深刻的是，她对作为一个成年人还带着毯子这件事感到一点也不羞耻。我和她在她公寓一个安静一点的地方谈了谈。不当调酒师时，亚伦在一个朋克摇滚乐队演奏，她还设计海报艺术。她的墙上装饰着这种艺术，有着鲜明的哥特风格。就像，这是我目前正在创作的东西。这里有一个头骨，还有一些恶魔和一些眼球，还有这个陷入出神状态的女人。亚伦告诉我，她的艺术是儿童想象力的表达。她的毛毯也差不多是同一样东西。它是
a way of keeping the good feelings of childhood alive. Can we, can we go get your blankie? I have it. Okay. I got it out because I knew that you had one to see it. Erin's blankie is a faded yellow quilt. You can see the outlines of stitched on teddy bears that fell off a long time ago. She likes to wrap it over her head like a huge scarf, and let me tell you the contrast is striking. Between her tattooed arms and those faded teddy bears.
一种让童年美好感觉保持鲜活的方式。我们能，我们能去拿你的毛毯吗？我有。好的。我把它拿出来了，因为我知道你也有，想看看。亚伦的毛毯是一条褪色的黄色被子。你可以看到缝在上面很久以前掉落的小熊的轮廓。她喜欢把它像一条巨大的围巾一样裹在头上，我得告诉你，这种反差是惊人的。在她有纹身的手臂和那些褪色的小熊之间。
Before I left Erin's apartment, I couldn't help but have a little blanky convention. Oh my gosh, yours is even more threadbare than mine. That's awesome. Mine is called Baba. It's called Baba. It's so soft. It is really soft, isn't it? It is.
在我离开亚伦的公寓之前，我不禁开了一个小型毛毯交流会。噢天哪，你的比我的还要破旧。太棒了。我的叫“巴巴”。它叫“巴巴”。它好软。真的好软，对吧？是的。
It's like a classic kind of. If you're? It is, it's like kind of. If you're laughing at us, that's fine. But maybe you're the weird one. I think it's weird that you wouldn't want to hold on to something from childhood that was a prized possession. There's one final issue about my Baba that I should address or let's say one final person. I'm Simon Rodberg, I'm the husband of Allison MacAdam who still loves her Baba.
这就像是一种经典。如果你？是的，这有点像。如果你在嘲笑我们，没关系。但也许你才是奇怪的那个人。我觉得奇怪的是，你竟然不想留住童年的某样东西，那可是件珍贵的物品。关于我的“巴巴”，还有一个最后的问题我应该谈谈，或者说最后一个人。我是西蒙·罗德伯格，我是艾莉森·麦卡达姆的丈夫，她依然爱着她的“巴巴”。
And my husband. Every night I climb into bed with Simon and with Baba. So what does he think of that? I suppose I thought that I might replace Baba at some point, that you never you'd ever married somebody before. Maybe Baba was just a placeholder until your husband got there. And I'm not quite sure what I realized. In fact, I would be sharing the bed with Baba rather than replacing Baba in your affections. And I think, no, I don't think I've minded, to be honest, I think, I love you, I love your Baba. That's just the way our marriage works. By the way, when I'm not in bed,
还有我的丈夫。每天晚上我都和西蒙还有“巴巴”一起上床睡觉。那么他是怎么想的呢？我想我曾以为在某个时候我会取代“巴巴”，你以前从未和任何人结过婚。也许“巴巴”只是一个权宜之计，直到你的丈夫出现。我不太确定我意识到了什么。事实上，我会和“巴巴”共用一张床，而不是在你的爱中取代“巴巴”。我想，不，说实话，我不介意，我想，我爱你，我爱你的“巴巴”。这就是我们婚姻的运作方式。顺便说一句，当我不在床上时，
Simon reaches over to my side of the bed, grabs Baba and snuggles with it himself. Baba reminds me of you. There's this thing that you've loved all your life and I don't know particularly I don't have a very good sense of smell. I don't know that it smells like you. It doesn't feel like you, but there's you in it. And so it's nice when I don't actually have you to be able to put my arms around something
西蒙会伸长胳膊够到我床的那一边，抓过“巴巴”自己抱着它。“巴巴”让我想起了你。有这样一样东西，你一生都在爱着它，我不知道，特别是我的嗅觉不是很好。我不知道它闻起来是不是像你。它摸起来也不像你，但里面有你的影子。所以，当我实际上没有你的时候，能够把双臂环抱在一个
that you love. So I hope all the grownups out there who still sleep with their blankets have partners who are as blah, blah positive as mine. NPR's Allison McHatham. When we come back, we'll hear about the pioneering scientist who first showed how cuddling with a blanket or loved one was not only not bad for us, it was absolutely essential to physical and mental well-being.
你爱的东西周围，这种感觉真好。所以我希望所有仍然抱着毯子睡觉的成年人们，都有像我一样对“巴巴”持积极态度的伴侣。NPR的艾莉森·麦卡达姆。稍后回来，我们将听到关于先锋科学家的故事，他首次证明了与毯子或心爱的人依恋不仅对我们没有坏处，而且对身心健康绝对至关重要。
These little baby monkeys would hold onto the cloth, they didn't want to let go, they were cuddling it, it made them feel safe in a way. Stay with us. Stay with us. When I first thought Alison McCatum's story about her comfort blanket, I remembered a wonderful book by the writer Debra Blum. It explored the powerful role that touch plays in our lives. Love at Goon Park tells the story of psychologist Harry Harlow and his groundbreaking experiments about
这些小猴子会紧紧抓住布料不放，它们不想放手，它们在依恋它，这以某种方式让它们感到安全。请继续收听。请继续收听。当我第一次听到艾莉森·麦卡达姆关于她的安慰毯的故事时，我想起了作家黛博拉·布鲁姆的一本精彩的书。它探讨了触摸在我们生活中发挥的强大作用。《爱在古恩公园》讲述了心理学家哈里·哈洛及其关于
attachment and affection. Deborah, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. It's great to be here. You describe in your book something that seems very surprising to me, which is that back in the 1950s, there were many prominent behavioral experts who believed that touch was a problem that children in particular shouldn't be caressed excessively shouldn't be held and cuddled excessively talked to me about that moment and where these experts were coming
依恋和情感的开创性实验的故事。黛博拉，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。你在书中描述了一件让我感到非常惊讶的事情，那就是在20世纪50年代，有许多著名的行为主义专家认为触摸是一个问题，特别是儿童不应该受到过度的抚摸，不应该被过度地抱和依恋，跟我谈谈那个时刻以及这些专家的观点是从哪里来的？
from. It's so fascinating to look back on that period and think to yourself how could you get that so wrong but it grew out of a kind of behaviorist idea that that kind of, you know, a solid foundation of affection as scientists, including ones I wrote about, would describe it. Didn't really matter. The mother was there as a food source, kept the kid warm, there as a food source kept the kid warm, answered its immediate physical needs, but the early books told mothers not to hold their children at all if they could avoid it, that it would ruin the moral fiber of the child. The child would become weak, the child would become dependent, the child would never become an independent human being.
回看那段时期，心里不禁会想，怎么会错得这么离谱，这真是太迷人了。但这源于一种行为主义的观点，即科学家（包括我写到过的那些）所描述的那种坚实的情感基础其实并不重要。母亲存在是为了提供食物来源，保持孩子温暖，存在是为了提供食物来源保持孩子温暖，满足其即时的生理需求，但早期的书告诉母亲们，如果能避免，就绝不要抱孩子，因为这会毁掉孩子的道德品质。孩子会变得软弱，孩子会变得依赖，孩子将永远无法成为一个独立的人。
So you spent a lot of time in the book talking about a very interesting and controversial figure who in some ways set the stage to overturn many of these ideas. So tell me about Harry Harlow, who he was, and how he came to his ideas. Yeah, Harry Harlow was a really fascinating, complicated, brilliant, difficult subject to write about. He's the center of Love at Goon Park, and I often described him as a charismatic, chain-smoking, poetry-writing, alcoholic, full-andering, work-a-ha-ha-like. Right, you can go on and on. And so the best and worst person to write about, because he inhabits your house while
所以在书中你花了很多时间讨论一个非常有趣且富有争议的人物，他在某种程度上为推翻这些观点奠定了基础。所以跟我讲讲哈里·哈洛，他是谁，以及他是如何形成他的观点的。是的，哈里·哈洛是一个非常迷人、复杂、才华横溢、难以撰写的传记对象。他是《爱在古恩公园》的核心，我经常将他描述为一个富有个人魅力、烟不离手、写诗的、酗酒的、风流的工作狂。没错，你可以说个没完。所以他是最好也是最难写的传记对象，因为在你写书的时候他会住进你的家里，而且他可不是个好相处的伙伴。但让他成为一个如此迷人且最终充满争议的人物的原因之一是，他在学术上无所畏惧。他是靈長類动物模型的早期开拓者之一，对吧？我们现在觉得这是理所当然的，但事实上，他在20世纪30年代去到威斯康星大学，从零开始在那里建立了一个早期灵长类动物群落，引进了少量的猴子，主要是恒河猴，它们是非常聪明、非常具社交性的东南亚猴子。他们当时遵循的是人类的模式。他们把小猴子和母亲分开。他们把它们放在无菌的
you're writing the book, and he's not easy company. But one of the things that made him such a fascinating and an eventually controversial subject was that he was intellectually fearless. He was one of the earlier developers of a primate model, right? We'd turn it take that for granted now, but in fact, he went to the University of Wisconsin in the 1930s and built an early primate colony there from scratch, bringing in a small number of monkeys, mostly recessed macaques, which are very smart, very social monkeys from Southeast Asia. And they were following kind of the, you know, human model. They kept their baby monkeys separate from the mothers. They kept them in sterile
环境中，这样就不会感染。它们被单独饲养。不过他们会给它们一块无菌尿布，作为它们在微小无菌笼子里睡觉时的垫衬和软布，当他们去拿走那块布换上一块干净的时，这些小猴子会紧紧抓住那块布不放。它们不想放手。它们依恋着它。
conditions so that, you know, there wasn't an infection. They were singly housed. They would give them though, like a sterile diaper, as kind of batting in a soft cloth to sleep in in their tiny sterile cage, when they would go to take out the cloth and put in another clean one, these little baby monkeys would hold onto the cloth. They didn't want to let go. They were cuddling it.
它们对它几乎产生了一种情感上的依恋，这种方式让所有的科学家都感到惊讶。而心理学领域中没有任何东西、绝对没有任何东西能够预测这一点，因为触摸并不重要，情感也不是幼儿早期发育的一部分。因此，哈洛看到这一点，他说，这意味着什么？于是，他和他的几个非常聪明的研究生坐下来，设计了一个项目，专门来研究触摸其实很重要的观点。跟我讲讲他所做的实验。所以他们做的事情其实非常巧妙。他们建造了两个版本的母亲，你可以称之为代孕母亲或机器人母亲。其中一个是用铁丝做的，另一个有一个铁丝身体，但外面包裹着一层可爱、舒适、厚实的布料垫衬。
They almost had an emotional attachment to it in ways that surprised all of the scientists. And there was nothing, absolutely nothing in the landscape of psychology that would have predicted this because touch didn't matter and emotions were not part of early childhood development. And so, Harla looked at this and he said, what does this mean? And so, he and a few of his very smart graduate students sat down and they designed a program just to look at the idea that touch actually mattered. Tell me about the experiments that he conducted. So what they did is really very brilliant. They built two versions of a mother, what you might call a surrogate or a robot mother. One of them is made of wire and one of them has a wire body but has a lovely, cuddly, thick, cloth padding.
它是铁丝母亲的温馨版本。它们都有脸，对吧？它们装上了脸，这与其说是为了猴子，不如说是为了研究人员。而且它们两个都是温暖的。他们在两者里面都装了灯泡。这样就能模拟母亲身体的温暖。然后他们会做的是，把铁丝妈妈和布妈妈放进
It's a cuddly version of the wire mother. Both of them have faces, right? They put on faces that was more for the researchers than for the monkeys. And both of them are warm. They put light bulbs in both of them. So it would simulate the warmth of a mother's body. And then what they would do is they would put wire mom and cloth mom in
关着小猴子的同一个围栏里。他们还会做另一件事。铁丝妈妈喂小猴子，对吧？有一个装有牛奶的瓶子。铁丝母亲拿着瓶子。布母亲唯一的优点是她温暖而舒适。他们在那里发现的是，小猴子们，它们就生活在布母亲身上。它们依恋并紧紧抓住不放，当它们饿了的时候，它们有这些布母亲。如果我能在你脑海中勾勒出这幅画面，
the same enclosure with baby monkeys. And they would do one other thing. Wire mom fed the baby monkeys, right? There was a bottle with milk. The wire mother held the bottle. Cloth mother her only virtue was that she was warm and cuddly. What they found there was that the baby monkeys, they lived on the cloth mother. They cuddled and held on and when they got hungry, they had these cloth mothers. If I could create this picture in your mind,
它们会有这两个并排的母亲。这些小猴子仍然紧紧抓着它们温暖舒适的布妈妈，把身子探过去，它们的头垂得刚刚好，足够它们够到牛奶。但它们就是不肯放手哈洛最终称之为接触安慰的东西。我们需要那种充满爱的触摸，就像我们需要食物一样。显然我们需要食物，但就我们成长为一个坚实、全面、付出、关怀、有联系的人而言，触摸更重要。因此，当哈洛做了这些实验，发现猴子为了蓬勃发展确实需要触摸时，当他向世界宣布这些想法时，各方的反应如何？
they would have these two mothers side by side. These little baby monkeys still holding on to their warm cuddly cloth mom will lean over their head tips over just far enough that they can get to the milk. But they're not going to let go of what Harlow eventually called contact comfort. We need that kind of loving touch as much as we need to be fed. Obviously, we need to be fed, but in terms of the way we grow up as a solid, well-rounded, giving, caring, connected person, the touch is more important. So when Harlow did these experiments and he found that the monkeys really needed touch in order to thrive, what was the reception to these ideas when he announced it to the world?
一开始完全是充满敌意的。他发表了一场演讲。这仍然是科学史上我最喜欢的演讲之一，叫做《爱的本质》，为了向你展示他是一个多么有趣的人，里面充满了打油诗。我的意思是，你不会经常看到这种类型。但他基本上是在科学界面前直言不讳地说，你们搞砸了，你们一直都在搞砸。他说，任何文学作品都比我们更懂得这一点。诗人们也比我们更懂得这一点。我们需要心理学赶上
Completely hostile in the beginning. He gave a speech. It's still one of my favorite speeches ever in the history of science called the nature of love, and to show you what an interesting guy he was, it's full of dog role poetry. I mean, you're not going to see this kind very often. But in which he basically got in the face of the scientific community and said, you've blown it, you've been blowing it. He said every literature gets this better than us. And poets get this better than us. And we need for psychology to catch up
基本的常识。他说，而且我认为这是对的，有很多父母都懂这个道理。他们不听你们的，因为你们搞错了，爱的本质关乎触摸和安慰，这也是哈洛信息中最让我喜欢的部分。爱的本质就是每一天。我都在你身边 这就是触摸所表达的。他提出了那个论点。它完全被当时仍然非常强大的行为主义社群所拒绝。但如果你看看接下来的十年左右发生了什么，他一直在推动它，他的研究生们带着这个信息走了出去，他们继续推动它。大约
with basic commons. And he said, and I think this is correct, there's a lot of parents who get this. They're not listening to you because you have gotten this wrong and the nature of love is about touch and comfort and my favorite part of the Harlem message. The nature of love is every day. I'm there for you Which is what touch says? He made that argument. It was completely He made that argument. It was completely rejected by the still very powerful behaviorist community. But if you look at what happens over the next decade or so, he keeps pushing it, his graduate students go out and take that message with them and they continue to push it. And about
在同一时期，或者不久之后，你会看到一位儿童心理学家站出来接受了它。所以并不是说当他发表那场演讲时火箭升空、烟花在空中闪耀，而是少数人听到了他的声音，并且他没有放弃。你知道的，黛博拉，我最初联系你，是因为我听到了艾莉森·麦卡达姆关于她的安全毯的故事。当我第一次听到艾莉森的故事时，让我震惊的一点是，在某种程度上，她对她依然深爱着这条童年的毯子、从毯子中获得如此多的安慰感到尴尬。而事实上，当我听她诉说并
the same time, or not too much later, you see a child psychologist come up and pick it up. So it wasn't that, you know, rocket swin off and fireworks dazzled in the sky when he gave the speech, but it was that a few people heard him and it was that he didn't give up. You know, I reached out to you, Deborah, in the first place when I heard Alison McCatum story about her security blanket. One of the things that struck me when I first heard Alison's story is that at some level she was embarrassed by the fact that she still loved this childhood blanket that she derived so much comfort from the blanket. And really as I listen to her and I
回想起你的书时，我脑海中真正蹦出的想法是，艾莉森只是一个极其正常的人。你在生活中实际上会有想要依恋的东西，甚至有睡前依恋的仪式感，这些都算不上什么可耻的事情。我完全同意。我想如果人们真的去想一想，你会发现，你生命中有这些时刻、对象或记忆，我们生命中有这些给我们带来安慰的节点。有时它是一件柔软舒适的东西。实际上，我保留着我儿子的一件小T恤，而他已经快27岁了
remember your book, the thing that really popped in my head was, you know, Allison is just profoundly normal. The idea that you would actually have things in your life that you would want to cuddle with or even things that you have a ritual of cuddling with before you go to sleep at night, these are hardly things to be ashamed about. I completely agree. And I think if people really think about it, you know, you have these moments or objects or memories, we have these points in our life that give us comfort. And sometimes it's something soft and cuddly. I actually, I have my son's tiny t-shirt and he's almost 27 years
，对吧？所以他穿这件衣服已经是二十多年前的事了。当我拿起那件衬衫时，它让我感到快乐。我想，如果我们真的坐下来审视自己的生活，这完全是正常的。这些我们可以触摸的事物提醒着我们是谁以及我们与什么相连，它们在我们的一生中给我们带来安慰。坦率我也很喜欢我们的这一特质。我也很喜欢我们的这一特质。我们都应该记住多拥抱。我希望我们能把今天的节目就停在这个甜蜜的音符上。
old, right? So he was wearing this more than two decades ago. And when I pick up that shirt, it makes me happy. I think, you know, if we actually sit and examine our own life, that's completely normal. These more things that we can touch that remind us of who we are and what we're connected to, that give us comfort throughout our lives. And frankly, I like that about us. I like that about us too. We should all remember to hug more. I wish we could end today's episode right here on the sweet note.
但还有更多的话要说。关于哈里·哈洛的故事还有更多，关于触摸在我们生活中的作用还有更多。是的，依恋很重要，童年的毛毯应该成为我们所有人生活的一部分。但还有更深层的教训，我们觉得如果不去探讨这些，那就太不诚实了。哈里·哈洛关于触摸重要性的实验在他经历了一场个人悲剧后走向了黑暗。他开始探索的不仅是爱的本质，还有它的对立面——孤立、忽视、虐待。
But there's more to say. There's more to Harry Harlow's story, and there's more to the role of touch in our lives. Yes, cuddling is important and childhood blankies ought to be part of all our lives. But there are deeper lessons, and we felt it wouldn't be honest if we didn't go there. Harry Harlow's experiments into the importance of touch took a dark turn after a personal tragedy in his life. He started to explore not just the nature of love, but its opposite, isolation, neglect, abuse.
这些实验永远玷污了他的名誉。谈论它们很重要，不仅因为这能更完整地记录他的一生，还因为这些实验对当今的社会政策有着深远的影响。我对哈里·哈洛感到最不安的是，一个花那么多时间思考爱和爱的重要性的人，也设计出了一些实验，尤其是在他晚年的时候，只能被描述为令人不安。几乎是折磨性的，对吧？
Those experiments permanently tarnished his reputation. It's important to talk about them not just because it provides a more complete account of his life, but because the experiments have profound implications for social policy today. What I find so disturbing about Harry Harlow is that someone who spends so much time thinking about love and the importance of love also came up with experiments, especially in his later years, that could only be described as disturbing. And almost torturous, right?
这些是极其挥之不去的恐怖实验，在动物保护界，他可能是20世纪最可怕的灵长类动物研究人员之一，因为他进行了抑郁症实验，当时他将抑郁症视为一种精神上的孤立。你能从那种状态中恢复过来吗？为了做到这一点，他实际上建造了不同的装置，将猴子与一切隔离开来，与它们的家人隔离开来，与其余的社群隔离开来，与任何形式的触摸（包括人类的触摸）隔离开来，他就把它们留在那里，然后把它们放出来，看看它们是否能够以
They're horribly haunting experiments and he's probably most famous in the animal rights community of being one of, you know, the most horrible of all primate researchers of the 20th century for the depression experiments in which he was looking at depression as sort of a mental isolation. Can you recover from that? And to do that, he actually built different devices that would isolate monkeys from everything, from their families, from the rest of the community, from any kind of touch, including human touch, and he would leave them there, and then he would bring them out and see if they could recover in
任何有意义的方式恢复。其中一些死去了，一些由于孤立而受到了永久性的损害。按照哈洛典型的方式，他将其中最臭名昭著的一个装置描述为“绝望之坑”，它本质上是一个倒金字塔。小猴子进入三角形的顶点。它敞开着，顶部有网眼，这样小动物就无法逃出去，无法被触摸，食物和水都有供应，但它孤零零地呆在这个顶点里。这太可怕了。
any meaningful way. Some of them dead, some of them were permanently damaged by the isolation. And in a very harlow way, he described probably the most infamous of those devices as the pit of despair, which was essentially an inverted pyramid. The baby monkey went into the point of the triangle. It opened up, wide armed with a mesh on top, so the little animal couldn't get bad out, couldn't be touched, food and water were supplied, but it was alone in this point. It was terrible.
我的意思是，我们讨论的是一个社会性物种，一个在触摸的舒适感中蓬勃发展的物种，而这一切全无。鉴于他对这些动物的了解，这些实验很难阅读，也很难理解，对吧？我并不为它们辩护。我只是做不到。而且我认为许多与他合作的心理学学生，他们也不为之辩护。他们证明了某个观点，但我并不确定那个观点是否需要
I mean, we're talking about a social species, and one that thrives in comfort of touch and there was none of that. And there are hard to read and hard to understand given what he knew about those animals, right? And I don't defend them. And I just can't. And I don't think many of the, you know, psychology students who work with them, they don't defend them either. They made a point, but I'm not sure that point needed to
以他那种方式来证明。他还做过其他黑暗的实验，引发了更复杂的问题。我想描述的那个实验较早，当时你正在研究接触安慰。关于布妈妈，他们发现了一件在思考发育时非常有趣的事情，那就是她从不拒绝，对吧。只要小猴子想要呆在那类温暖、毛茸茸的布料拥抱中，她就在那里。而现实中有大量的人在许多方面都是不太理想的父母。我们能研究这个吗？
be made the way he made it. He did other experiments that are dark, that raised some more complicated issues. And the one I wanted to describe came earlier in which you're looking at contact comfort. One of the things they discovered about cloth mom which was really interesting in thinking about development is that she never rejected right. As long as the baby monkey wanted to be in that sort of warm, fuzzy cloth embrace, she was there. And there are plenty of human beings who are less than ideal parents in many ways. Can we study that?
于是他们建造了一系列他所谓的“邪恶母亲”，它们确实很邪恶。他们建造了一个布妈妈，布里嵌入了钝刺。所以当小猴子靠近并紧紧抱住时，刺会弹出来把它推开。他们预测所有的猴子最后都会精神错乱。他们在那些孤立实验中确实得到了精神错乱的结果。但在这种情况下，发生的事情是小猴子并没有精神错乱，它们回来试图修复这段关系。一等刺缩回去，它们就会回来，试图让她爱它们。它们紧紧抓住，发出咕咕声，依恋着，讨好着，
And they built a series of what he called evil mothers and they were evil. They built a cloth mother and in the cloth was embedded blunt spikes. And so when the baby monkey comes and clings, the spikes will shoot out and push it off. And they predicted all the monkeys would end up psychotic. They actually got psychosis with those isolation experiments. But in this case what happened was that the baby monkeys didn't become psychotic, they came back and tried to fix the relationship. And as soon as the spikes retracted, they'd come back and they'd try to make her love them. And they'd hold on and they'd coup and they'd cling and they'd flirt and
做着所有婴儿都会做的事。小猴子婴儿和人类婴儿。爱我，对吧？让我做所有这些能让你想要和我在一起的事。为了修复这一点，它们会放弃所有其他关系，对吧？直接放弃，你知道的，不再和它们的朋友混在一起。它们需要先修复那个最基本的关系。这太让人心碎了，对吧？想到这些小动物和孩子们，这让人心碎。然后，在我四处巡回宣传《爱在古恩公园》出版后的一次演讲中，我描述了这些实验，之后来了一位女士，她是当地医院一个病房的护士，那里治疗
they do everything babies do. Monkey babies and human babies. Love me, right? Let me do all of these things that will make you want to be with me. And they would abandon all their other relationships to fix this, right? Just give up, you know, wouldn't hang out with their friends. They needed to fix that first fundamental relationship. It's heartbreaking, right? It's heartbreaking to think about it for these little animals and for children. And then one of the things that struck me the most when I went out, I was book touring after Love at Goon Park came out and I gave a talk and I described these experiments and this woman came up afterwards and she was a nurse in a unit at the hospital there that treated
忽视和虐待的成年幸存者，她对我说，你描述的是我们的病人，对吧，他们已经30岁、40岁、50岁或更大了，他们和你描述的一样大，而且他们仍然在试图修复最初的那段关系。我也能从中看到一些回响，比如我们围绕例如单独监禁以及单独监禁对人类的影响及他们身上发生的事情所进行的辩论。当然，哈里·哈洛并不是唯一一个在这方面做过工作的人，但感觉其中依然有着与儿童虐待和单独监禁、或者人类在被剥夺触摸很久很久很久之后所发生的事情之间的强烈回响。
the adult survivors of neglect and abuse and she said to me, well you're describing our patients right and they're 30 or 40 or 50 or older, you're as old and they're still trying to fix that first relationship. I can see echoes also with sort of the debates we've had over, for example, solitary confinement and sort of the effects of solitary confinement on human beings and what happens to them. And Harry Harlow is not the only one who's done work on this, of course, but it feels again that they're just such strong echoes with child abuse and solitary confinement or what happens in human beings when they deprive of touch long, long, long after they've stopped being
我们已经做过这些实验了。我们不必再做一次。我们绝不应该再做一次。但我们应该倾听它们的意见，因为它们确实告诉了我们关于单独监禁的深刻道理。对吧？人们本该更多地倾听他们关于触摸的意见，关于我所认为的“厨房之爱”、爱是一种日常品质的重要性的意见。他们仍然传达着重要的信息，你可以爱或恨哈里·哈洛，人们
children. We've done these experiments. We don't have to do them again. We should never do them again. But we should listen to them because they do tell us profound things about solitary confinement. Right? They should have been listened to a lot more about touch, about the importance of what I think of as, you know, kitchen love, love is an everyday quality. They still have an important message and you can love or hate Harry Harlow and people
两者兼有，对吧？但其中的一些信息、一些理念、他试图教给我们的某些东西依然重要。黛博拉·布鲁姆是普利策奖得主、《爱在古恩公园》的作者。本期《隐藏的大脑》由玛吉·佩恩曼和珍妮·施密特制作。我们的工作人员包括卡拉姆·阿古尔克-阿利森、马克斯·内斯特拉克和克里斯·本德夫。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上找到我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这期节目，请在iTunes或你收听播客的任何地方写一篇评论，这会帮助其他人找到这个节目。
do both, right? But some of the messages, some of the ideas, some of the things that he tried to teach still matter. Deborah Blum is the Pulitzer Prize-winning author of Love at Goon Park. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Pennman and Jenny Schmidt. Our staff includes Karam Agurk-All Allison, Max Nestrak and Chris Benderf. You can find us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen to my stories on your local public radio station. If you liked this episode, please write a review on iTunes or wherever you listen to podcasts, it'll help others find the show.
我是尚卡尔·维丹特姆，这是NPR。这也是NPR。该剧集尚无评论。点击转录文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I'm Sean Curvey-Tantham and this is NPR. and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是肖恩·柯维-坦瑟姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。